vous chantal j'avais plusieurs choix
mais vous l'avez pas celui que je vais
vous nommez le fait que la loi
québécoise sur l'aide médicale à mourir
et pas au niveau du jugement de la cour
suprême sur le suicide de cet événement
et votre événement à surveiller dans
notre bilan loin la même et je vais pas
marcher parce que on se promène
aujourd'hui là en principe la loi vient
de rentrer en vigueur c'est un moment
historique cette loi là n'est pas au
niveau des exigences de la cour suprême
et le jour où le jugement de cour
suprême va être mise en vigueur et ils
veulent l'être par le gouvernement de
monsieur trudeau le québec va avoir deux
choix d'utiliser la clause de dérogation
pour protéger sa loi actuelle des
exigences de la cour suprême ou la
réécrire